diese Woche und das finde ich toll hat
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing mal ein
ganz klares Zeichen gesetzt und zwar
gegen Altersdiskriminierung deutsche
Senioren können auch in Zukunft so lange
Autofahren bis sie während der Fahrt
friedlich
einschlafen Volker ist also ab sofort
der Held aller Best Ager und
äh das das ist ja im Gegensatz zur
Europäischen Union denn die will mit
einer verkehrsrichtlinie ü70 Fahrer
zwingen alle 5 Jahre den Führerschein
aufzufrischen gut jedes EU-Land dürfte
wählen zwischen ärztlicher Untersuchung
oder Selbsteinschätzung ne letztlich
müsste man dann einen Fragebogen
ausfüllen einzige Hörde wä die
Schriftgröße ne aber trotzdem nicht mit
mir sagt Volker Wissing denn das würde
unsere Gesellschaft ich zitiere den
Minister unmenschlicher machen und wohl
auch manche Schaufenster sicherer aus
Versehen das falsche Pedal erwischt und
schon kracht es meistens verursacht von
Seniorinnen und Senioren ein 77-jähriger
verwechselt Gas und Bremse eine Seniorin
kracht mit ihrem Auto durch den
Seiteneingang deren Fahrer haben wohl
Gas und Bremse verwechselt und das war
der doppeltäter der mit seinem kpriolet
auch schon im Blumengeschäft
stand ja wenn die auch immer so kleine
Preisschilder im Schaufenster haben muss
man halt näher ranfahren damit man die
lesen kann ist do logisch demnächst bei
Pro 7 die große tvttal Schaufenster
Crash Challenge natürlich fahren ältere
Menschen kürzere Strecken aber auf den
Kilometer umgerechnet sind sie zusammen
mit den Fahranfängern eben doch die
fleißigsten Unfallverursacher und bei
den über 75-Jährigen sind drei von vier
Fahrern Hauptverursacher dieser Unfälle
klar hat Volker Wissing nicht unrecht
wenn er fragt ja womit sollen Senioren
denn sonst fahren auf dem Land bei dem
miesen ÖPNV und ich sag mal so wenn er
jetzt noch rauskriegt wenn er jetzt noch
rauskriegt welcher Verkehrsminister
dafür verantwortlich ist dann ist was
los wissings Vorschlag die Menschen
sollen weiter selber einschätzen ob sie
noch gut fahren können und das ist mutig
in einem Land wo wirklich jeder denkt
alle fahren Scheiße außer
ich bei mir stimmt das zufällig aber bei
allen anderen Selbsteinschätzung wie oft
liegt man da total daneben wenn man z.B
denkt hey ich kann doch auch mit 85 noch
Ecstasy einwerfen und abraven die Chicks
drehen durch warum nicht mit über 70 ins
Tattoo Studio gehen und sich was cooles
stechen lassen wo die anderen im
Altenheim voll neigisch werden und
natürlich gibt's auch Seniorinnen die
sich einreden sie hätten noch politische
Relevanz
ah ja aber ist schon ist schon
interessant oder das Auto muss man bei
uns alle zwei Jahre zum TÜV bringen und
checken lassen bei Menschen reicht
Selbsteinschätzung nachzulesen in dem
Buch der hundtjährige der aus der dem
Fenster schieg und alles zu
klumpfuhr natürlich wird z.B der
Schulterblick mit den Jahren schwieriger
merke ich ja sogar schon und natürlich
lässt das Reaktionsvermögen nach man
nennt es Biologie und die ist
gnadenlos mir hat Senior offenbar
geglaubt er habe den Rückwärtsgang drin
hat aber den Vorwärtsgang drin was jedem
anderen auch passiert nur der braucht
eine zehntel Sekunde um das zu verstehen
und wenn man eine Sekunde braucht ist
man eben schon im Schaufenster und
deswegen ist es so klassisch ja es gibt
eine einfache Eselsbrücke rückwärts ist
wenn die Rückwärtskamera angeht vorwärts
ist wenn der Airbag aufgeht ne kann man
sich merken so mein Vorschlag wäre alle
alle Bürger frischen den Führerschein
alle paar Jahre auf dann wär es nämlich
keine
Altersdiskriminierung auch das
Theoriewissen zum Führerschein ruhig mal
aktualisieren man vergisst so viel über
die Jahre denn frappieren falsch können
die Antworten auf diese simple Frage
sein wie lautet die Grundregel der
Vorfahrt an Kreuzungen und
einmindungen der Radfahrer muss
warten ja nee ist leider
falsch leider falsch
ja war aber nah
dran richtige Antwort wä natürlich der
Mann hat immer Vorfahrt so wichtig ist
seine eigenen Eltern oder ich sag mal
ältere Nachbarn rechtzeitig anzusprechen
wenn man merkt jetzt wird's gefährlich
bei ihm oder ihr und da gibt's ja
Hinweise also zumindest wenn man ein
Auge hat für die Details erstes Indiz
sind oft so kleine Kratzer von
Verteilerkästen die man versehentlich
mitgenommen hat oder wenn man z.B am
autohck noch die Auslage von den
Blumenladen hat in den man neulich
rückwärts reingebrettert ist und
natürlich der freche
lierandoobote der auf seiner Vorfahrt
bahen wollte selber
Schuld der ADAC argumentiert übrigens
auch gegen die Überprüfung elterer MitB
Bürger weil ein gutes Testergebnis die
Fahrer dazu verleiten könnte ihre
Fähigkeiten weit zu
überschätzen das ist auch eine Logik
würde ich mal sagen ne Deutschland ist
nur noch eins von vier EU-Ländern ganz
ohne Medizincheck im Alter immerhin
werden bei uns aber sogenannte
rückmeldefahrten angeboten da kann man
sich ein wohlgemerkt unverbindliches
Feedback zu den eigenen Fähigkeiten am
Steuer
einholen
so Heinz du hast sie alle erwischt
bestanden
ja sowas wird schon angeboten Feedback
und es ist jetzt wirklich nicht böse
gemeint aber es hat ja Gründe dass
Autoversicherung mit dem Alter bei uns
immer teurer werden apropos Versicherer
laut einer neuen Studie der
Autoversicherer hat die Aggressivität
auf deutschen Straßen unabhängig vom
Alter der Fahrer massiv zugenommen
keiner weiß warum vielleicht liegt liegt
an all den Krisen der insgesamt
schlechten Stimmung jedenfalls wird mehr
gedrängelt Licht gehubt und ausgebremst
höchste Zeit also dass diese Sendung
hier endlich
zurückkommt man sieht es ihm nicht an
aber der deutsche Autofahrer ist das
gefährlichste Säugetier der Welt 50% der
Fahrer sagen dass sie sich bei Ärger im
Straßenverkehr sofort abreagieren müssen
hallo her KL ich habe ein Einschreiben
für sie siehst du nicht dass ich weg
muss du dämlich Scheiße forscher
versuchen zu ergrüen was die Quelle
dieserosenut sein könnte 78% der
Geschwindigkeitsverstöße werden bei uns
von Männern begangen nur 22% von Frauen
sieh Männer sind die Raser si Männer
sind die Raser ja weil wir Termine haben
und richtige Berufe zu dem man pünktlich
kommen muss
außerdem habt ihr beim fahren ja ganz
andere Probleme viele Frauen scheuen das
Anlegen des Sicherheitsgurts weil sie
Angst um ihren Busen haben diese Sorge
ist unnötig sagen Mediziner endlich am
Ziel und schon
R mach die Tür auf ohne zu gucken die
blöde alte mit ihrem
Busen mach die nicke Spur frei du Penner
jeder fünfte Mann benutzt regelmäßig die
Lichthupe ja damit die anderen Idioten
auch was lernen ich habe ja schließlich
einen pädagogischen Auftrag und
31% treten gelegentlich sogar aufs
Gaspedal wenn sie überholt werden das
könnte dir so passen Freundchen ne guck
mal das Schwein will mich überholen hast
du dir den Falschen
ausgesucht marchtin Hände ans Lenkrad ah
Fresse wir haben spurhalter Assistenten
so lies mal was du bist du haopai
leider entpt sich der haopai im
konkreten Fall als Polizist in Zivil
Martin ist den Lappen los scheiße und
muss nun für mehrere Monate die
ultimative Demütigung ertragen jeden
Morgen mit den anderen Losern im fucking
Bus zur Arbeit es wird ihm keine Lehre
[Musik]
sein hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den
Kanal abonnieren nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen
[Musik]
Dank